[Music]  all my life i tried to forget my past  my dad in the ten rings on september 3rd  you were meant for greatness don't hide  who you really are  i'm nothing like you  hell yeah  we missed the rise  of a marvel legend my name is  shanji  shan shang  that's what i said pg-13  for thousands of years  the ten rings  gave our family  legendary power  my son  now  they call to you  i'm not who you think i am  marvel studios of the ten rings rated  pg-13  if i die it's your fault  september 3rd i know that you don't like  to talk about your life but a guy with a  freaking machete foreign arm just  chopped our butts in half  who are you  on september 3rd my father trained me to  be an assassin and that's not who i am a  marvel legend  will rise my name is  you're such a badass thank you  marvel studios shanghai and the legend  of the ten rings ready pg-13 in theater  september 3rd  you